Thank you so much for making connections
with each other. We really appreciate um
all that you do um who you are and who
you represent and uh thank you for being
here for our kids. Um if you don't know
me, we do have some visitors in the
room. My name is Paula. I'm the very
proud principal of Maplewood Elementary.
[cheering]
I do have some quick announcements. Um,
in case you need to scoot out um early,
if you just need to take a break, we do
have the library. Uh, that is an open
space for you. Um, um, just wanted to
make sure that you knew that that was
available. Um, in case you need to leave
um, to get somewhere, please exit
through the rear and then you can exit
back out the front and then just remove
your name tag as you go. We really
appreciate you. And then thank you so
much parents for pre-registering. That
helped us all get the whole family in
much quicker this morning. Um, I do have
some announcements. I'm going to make
most of my announcements at the end.
This does serve as my Friday coffee. Uh,
but just in case, I wanted to make you
very aware that we do have a book
character parade. Huge event here at
Maplewood. It happens this Friday at 8
o'clock. Uh, please uh come and attend.
It'll last about 15 minutes. Um, and
we'll do it in the cafeteria. So, you'll
need to badge in and then come in the
cafeteria and then we will parade um all
of our wonderful kiddos in their book
character costumes uh through this venue
for you to see and be a part of. Uh once
again, thank you for bringing uh your
whole self here today. Thank you for
being adult peacemakers. Um and thank
you for what you represent. Thank you
for how much you love your kids. I'll
turn it over to Ally from the district.
Awesome.
Good morning everyone. My name is Ally
Gillarduchi. I'm the senior executive
director of communications and community
engagement. Um I'm just going to go over
our agenda, the meeting purpose, and
some norms. Um and then I'm going to
pass it over to our superintendent to
kind of welcome everyone and share a
little about the vision. But we've
already had our welcome. Um I'll go over
the norms and the purpose. Um I'll
introduce some of the folks that we have
here to help answer questions. Um, and
then we wanted we had some ideas come
from your community. I think you all
provided us with three options you
wanted us to consider. So, um, if there
are folks here that are, um, wanting to
actually kind of orient everyone to
those three options, we we welcome our
PTA to the PTA to come up and kind of
share that, but we have those ready to
kind of discuss. Um, we also pulled
questions from the comment cards that
y'all have done. Um, and so we have some
of those pulled and prepared if we want
to make sure that we get answers to
those common questions that came up
through the comment cards. Um, and then
we're going to discuss next steps. Um,
and so for our meeting norms, we are
here to build the future together. We
and we appreciate I think that y'all did
this through the proposal that you had
is just acknowledging the challenges of
our current situation while focusing on
ideas and solutions that will make our
district stronger, more equitable, and
sustainable for years to come. We want
to honor time. So, when we do invite
folks to um ask questions that maybe
weren't answered in the comment cards,
we ask that people try to limit their
comments to about a minute. We have a
lot of folks and we want to create space
for everyone. We want to honor the
process. So, um we'd like to try to stay
on schedule on the agenda. Um we want to
honor intent and impact. So, we may
disagree on ideas, but I hope that we
can all agree that we're here um to
focus on our shared goal of having
strong schools um for every single child
in our district. Um, we want to honor
space and voice. So, if you speak one
time, we're going to ask that we make
sure that we let others speak before we
come back to the same person to speak.
Um, we're going to try to
solutionoriented. So, focusing on ideas
and solutions and understanding. Um, and
we want to embrace transparency and
empathy. We know these are really
difficult conversations. Um, and we are
here to be transparent, open, and honest
with you about um, kind of the
constraints that we face and what ideas
we think that we can maybe further
explore and what ideas maybe just aren't
options. Um, these are our norms in
Spanish.
Um, and the meeting purpose. So, like I
said, we want to respond to questions
submitted via the comment card and
provide opportunities for y'all to have
follow-up questions. We want to discuss
the ideas that y'all have developed. Um,
and then we want to we as an
administration want to gain insights
that will inform potential refinements
to the draft plan before the November 20
vote. Before I hand it over to
superintendent, I just want to let y'all
know kind of the staff that's here real
quick. Um, so I'm going to go ahead and
let them introduce themselves real
quick.
>> Good morning everyone. Christine
Steampport, operations officer.
>> Hi, good morning. Rachel French, uh,
director of planning and project manager
of the consolidations.
>> Good morning. Sandra McWills, elementary
executive director that supports
Maplewood.
>> Good morning. Cherry Lee, interim
assistant superintendent of special
education and health services.
>> Good morning. Victoria O'Neal, executive
director of um campus and family
engagement.
>> Good morning. I'm Amanda Reyes, director
of evaluations for special education.
>> Hi, I'm Marian Maxwell and the assistant
superintendent of academics.
>> Good morning. My name is Ibec Gardinus
and I'm the executive director of
academic programs um pleasure of working
with multilingual education and early
learning and just really quickly want to
thank the folks that we have for my team
that are recording our interpreters so
that we can make this meeting accessible
to our Spanish speaking families as
well. Um go ahead um Superintendent
Siguru we're going to let you kind of
share a little about the vision.
>> So uh thank you everybody for showing up
this morning. Um,
these are difficult conversations. Uh,
and the worst thing that could happen is
for us not to engage, have a
deliberation, and talk about kind of
what this is, the moment we're in, and
what we as a school district are trying
to tackle. So, I very much appreciate
you all showing up. And I also
acknowledge just how painful and
disruptive this is. Uh, our entire city
is going through a transition. Our
schools are the foundation of our entire
city. I've said that at every step along
my journey. I believe it in my heart.
Our city like has can only thrive if
there are strong schools in it.
With that being said, it's not true that
we have strong schools everywhere in
Austin.
That's that is not a that is not a fact.
Right now, we have some schools that
have the ability to provide the
resources to all of their students and
meet their needs. And we have some some
schools that cannot.
This is not a function of our students,
not a function of our staff. It's a
function of our inability as a school
district to provide those resources,
right? And this isn't a just built up
over 144 years.
There are things that we have done over
the last many, many decades that have
led us to this moment.
And so as we move forward, one of the
things that we have to do is we just
have to evolve as a school district.
If we want to save who we are as an
independent school district and educate
in a way that aligns with our values, we
just have to change.
And so when we took on this effort
several months ago, and you think about
just the work coming out of the long
range plan, one of the things we talked
about is we wanted to have thriving
neighborhood schools, right? schools in
your neighborhood so that you as a
family did not have to go across town to
find a school that met your students
needs. Right now, we know that there are
lots of families in parts of town that
travel very, very far. We know that
because of our transfer rates. We know
where they live and we know that we know
where they go to school.
And so if we're going to move towards
having strong neighborhood schools, we
needed to rethink how we function, how
we operate, and also acknowledge that
there are lots of pressures hammering
down on us. That is a fact.
So I think about the moment we're in, I
think about the fact that we've had
declining enrollment.
We live in a city where it's very, very
expensive to live, right? that has
pushed out so many families and we know
this. We see it. It's the city has grown
that's occurred. It's something that
certainly we have a role in playing, but
we cannot disrupt in a way that would
allow families to come back. We just not
here. Two, state of Texas, you all know
this better than anybody, not funding
public education. In 2023, we were
praying, we were hoping that they would
fund us. Didn't happen. Two years later,
we get some amount ultimately nets out
to about $10 million in our $1 billion
operating budget. Doesn't move the
needle.
Then we think about the changes in the
federal government.
So the changes in the federal government
have impacted us to a degree that is
hard to communicate. In the last year
alone, we had title two, title three,
and title four funding get frozen like
effect essentially overnight. had over
hundred people I shared this last night
in a room telling them that they're not
going to be employed by Austin IC
because the way that you're funded is
sourced by title two, title three and
title four dollars and those dollars are
going away next year. You had on top of
that immigration changes and policy
changes that have kept immigrant
families from coming to Austin
and then those that are here have left.
We're down about 2,500 students this
year alone and they're all in one part
of town. We know who they are. We know
where they went to school. We know their
families. And many of them are still
here. They're just not comfortable
coming to school.
And so we're trying to also
move through a ever changing
accountability system.
Right? In 2022,
we had 19 schools that 17 schools that
were a B that ultimately were an F the
following year. same students, same
educators,
right? And so as we think about what had
to happen, it had to be something that
was sizable, significant enough for us
to move forward and really change how we
operate. So this plan is complex. It's
multi-layered. There are lots of things
in it. We'll talk about them, but I want
you to know that there are five really
fundamental things that we were trying
to address. First is we wanted to align
feeder patterns.
Right? In parts of Austin, you have
clean feeder patterns. You know where
they are, right? You can have students
at Mkersonen that wear Anderson Trojan
hats. 100% of that school goes into
Anderson, right? Geritzky, Buoie, Oh,
Henry, Austin High. Where do you not
have that? East Austin. You have Doby
going into three high schools. You have
Martin going into five.
Mendes going into four. You cannot keep
community together if you have that type
of fragmented feeder pattern. So we
wanted to address that. Two,
we had to acknowledge that we are
running a budget deficit. We have been
and unless we become more efficient,
we're not going to be able to get out of
it. And one-time capital injection
selling land or you know revenue from
some donor that is not sustainable
revenue.
It isn't. Last thing we want to do is to
create a disruption where students are
left in a system and that's precisely
what happened when the title two, title
three and title four dollars were
frozen. So we really need to look at our
inefficiencies which included kind of
balancing enrollment which ultimately
led to consolidations.
Big part of why we're here today. Third
thing we wanted to stabilize our
programming.
I'm going to talk specifically about
wallto-all language because it's
embedded in this in this specific plan
as well as monastery. But I want to talk
about wallto-wall. So the four programs
that are part part of this plan that are
moving, you know, when you look at the
emerging bilingual student population
that the program was intended to serve,
those numbers are moving in the wrong
direction. Why is that?
Because those families do not live in
that neighborhood and they can't access
that program.
So what do you do? Provide access.
So to make to improve accessibility, we
are moving the programs to where they
live. And we're going to make
adjustments. and we'll talk about what
that looks like to ensure that they're
invited, they're comfortable, they're
welcomed into those school communities.
But when you have schools that have 14,
21, 22, and 44% emerging bilingual
student populations are moving in the
wrong direction, you know that if you
don't stabilize in the next couple
years, when the law takes full effect
and I have to place dual language
educators that are certified in
classrooms that have the students, those
classes and those schools will not have
the educators to be sufficient to be
stabilized. Want to tackle that. We also
want to tackle our crazy transfer
policies that we have. They've been in
place for decades. We have majority
minority. We have diversity choice. We
have lots of other ones. And we as a
school district do not manage it well.
They're not managed the at the district
level are managed many times at the
local level. And so you see schools tip
over where they'll go to 120 130%
because the they continue to accept
transfers. We really needed to take hold
of that. The last thing I'll say is we
had to acknowledge that this
accountability risk that we're
navigating, the fact that 23, 24, and 25
accountability came out back to back to
back within five months of each other.
If we do not break these accountability
chains, right, the three unacceptable
ratings,
the two, we will not be able to move
forward. I promise you it is a real
risk.
We have a part we have a sister school
district right now that's navigating
being taken over by the state our same
size almost exactly
and there are decisions I know they wish
they would have made two or three years
ago. We are desperately trying to put
ourselves in a position I we're
desperately trying to put ourselves in a
position where that doesn't happen and
that is a risk that we have to navigate.
We just have to break them. We have to
break those accountability chains. So,
when it comes to this plan, as you all
know, um this plan uh includes having uh
Maplewood [snorts] wholly go into
Campbell Elementary School. Uh we'll
talk about the data that was used. We'll
talk about how we look at different
areas. We talk about the number of seats
that we have to pull out of the system.
Uh we'll talk about what it's going to
look like. I'm sorry.
>> So, when we'll
get into comments and questions,
So, okay. So, the the plan is for the
school as a whole. We'll talk about what
issues or what adjustments need to be
made going into Campbell. Um, one of the
things that we know, and this is where
we really have to think through what uh
disruption looks like, we recognize that
each community has a different culture,
different uh diversity of students. And
so the one thing that we cannot do is
take away the ability to to plan a
thoughtful transition. That has to be
part of this work. That has to be. So
you want So what does this mean? I mean
y'all y'all under understand that this
means that if you live in the current
Maplewood elementary school attendance
boundary, you will move and be
reassigned to Campbell Elementary
School, right? Starting this at the 26
27th school year. So next year. Matias,
I think we want to clarify something.
So, the um the full population does fit,
but I think the second bullet point is
something we wanted to touch on because
this is what was initially proposed was
that transfers um could return to their
zone school or apply for a transfer and
with the draft that we're going to
release if you want to share kind of the
changes we're doing to that. So one of
the things uh thank you Ally that we
wanted to provide extreme clarity around
was uh where we have scenarios where the
transfer policy or the transfer
operating procedures weren't clear um we
wanted to create clarity. So we made
several changes. One of the ones that
you're going to see on October 30th this
Friday is that if you have a student who
has transferred into a school like
Maplewood, they will 100% be approved to
transfer into whatever school that that
school is moving into. the cohort.
So, um this is one of those things where
I want y'all to know like we this is
already disruptive enough.
It's painful, but we never wanted to
introduce something um that created
unnecessary disruption. And so, this is
something we can do. We're committing to
it. The numbers work. Um, we also are
going to be uh approving sibling
transfers automatically.
So, this is something you'll see in
October 30th. Right now, um, I will tell
you that myself, our board of trustees,
none of us ever want a family to go to
drop their third grader off and then go
drop a kindergarten off at a different
school. That's not who we are. We've
never wanted that. Now, I understand why
the plan and our policies and the way
the words are written ultimately um got
us to that point. But whenever we see
those transfers, we approve them
immediately. The only time we don't do
it if it's a applicationbased program
like an an Richards or a Lassa, right?
You you really need to be applying to
get into those schools. So that's that's
that's why we don't do it for those. But
that will also be a change. So we
approve them, but it's typically through
um an appeal process. So, what we're
going to do is say, you know what,
guaranteed move forward. We've run the
numbers. This it it works. Um, so that's
one of the differences. This slide deck,
this work um was all based off the
October 3rd um version of the plan. And
I'm very mindful of version control that
I don't make a change here and they
don't communicate to some other
communities. So, I really wanted to make
sure we kind of held the line, shared
with you changes verbally, and then
October 30th when it changes, everybody
sees it at one time.
Also, just to clarify, it's the 31st.
It's going to be out um in the Friday
before we're going for before noon on
Friday.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Sorry. I keep thinking it's 31
days. You want to go to the next slide,
Ally. Please,
>> you want Christine, you
>> Hi everyone. You probably seen the
boundary map as a part of our first
deliverable, but I just wanted to kind
of go over that for anybody else um that
hasn't seen it. So here is the current
Maplewood boundary. So live in this
area. This is zoned to Maplewood. And so
because this zone is closing, proposed
to close. If you can go to the next
slide, this whole boundary would just
move and shift um straight to the
Campbell boundary. So just kind of
wanted to showcase that we have a little
portion here we call feathering to make
sure that we can make a little bit fit.
And we've got this that is going to be
um uh uh zoned to Blackshere to make
them a little bit uh more whole and
healthy in that as well. Oh, excuse me.
Excuse me. Black Shar to Campbell and
also here Blackshar to Campbell as well.
So that was just Thank you. That coffee
has not kicked in.
So yes, and so that's what that looks
like right here and right here and the
bit the bit of the feathering.
Okay. So, we just wanted to make sure
that everyone was kind of oriented to
what was initially proposed. Um, and so
I want to kind of put it to y'all
because we have two options in terms of
how we spend the rest of our time. We
did, like I said, prepare some of those
frequently asked questions that came up
in the comment cards. So, we can jump
into that and start kind of going over
that or if you prefer, we can just go
right into the three options that y'all
um kind of prepared. Um, do we have I'm
going to go show of hands if you want to
get to the questions.
Okay.
>> Okay. So, you'd rather start with the
questions and maybe that the options can
be part of the discussion as we get into
that. That sounds good. Um, appreciate
that everyone. Um, so getting started.
Um, this was one that came from multiple
commenters, but why close an A-rated
near capacity neighborhood school like
Maplewood? What data and criteria
justify this decision?
>> So,
One of the things I want to say is um
we've spent the last couple years
talking about how the accountability
system has shifted and changed and the
fact that there are B schools one year
and F schools the next year. We talk a
lot about the fact that there are lots
of schools that have D's and Fs assigned
to them, not by us but by the state of
Texas and they have just as many people
advocating for their school because they
love their school. There are incredible
things happening in their school. And so
when we started this process, when I
tell you we did not start with
accountability in mind, that is a fact.
That was never the case because if we
did that, we would do the opposite and
only consolidate or only close schools
that historically not performed. So
that's why we didn't start there. That
being said, whenever you have
inefficiencies in a school district as
large as ours, serving 70,000 students
with 116 schools, and if we got to a
place where we had high performing
schools everywhere, you would still have
that inefficiency. There are school
districts right now that are closing
high performing schools everywhere
because they're still very inefficient.
So there I I want you to know that it's
not it's something that we consider.
It's something we talk about, but it's
not something that we led with. It's not
something that we led with. Um, but that
is why we didn't use accountability to
drive the decision. There are other
schools, as you all know, in the plan,
uh, that have performed higher
historically. Um, but it wasn't what
drove the efficiency conversation. Now,
the other alternative is move Campbell
into Maplewood, right? Then you think
about, okay, well, historic hang, let me
let me
I know. So one of the things we don't
want to do we know is that would
introduce historical harm right that
school um being the culture the student
population what we know based on the
work we've done around uh equity
movement and transition work is going to
be extremely harmful that to that
community and so given that this is the
the thing we're trying to address in
this larger area there aren't lots of
options for us there just isn't so uh
that is why that you will see in this
plan some adjustments and transitions
around schools that have historically
performed better.
>> I'm gonna allow this person to ask a
followup.
>> Hey, thank you. Hi, I'm Dr. Julie Shu.
I'm a Maplewood parent here. I'm also a
licensed psychologist and I have my PhD
in school psychology. Um I'm really
concerned about a few things um related
to this. So um yeah what I know what you
all know and decades of educational
research show is that um we need you
know low ratios for math and reading
interventionists
for school counselors for special
education support teachers for LSSPs for
diagnosticians
and that's what leads to academic
success for kids as you all know um so
my concern is
with us moving proposed moving to
Campbell um what's going to happen to
the title one funding for Campbell. My
understanding is that that's how they
fund their interventionist right now. We
actually had to the PTA had to fund
raise to have a part-time math
interventionist for our school with the
with the um intention to bring up more
equity in our student body. Um which we
did achieve. Um we have 122 students
from economically disadvantaged
backgrounds here at Meeplewood. Um, so
I'm just really concerned how is this
plan going to prioritize this um low
student to interventionist ratio across
the board for social emotional for
academics um given that's what's
evidence-based and needed to improve
outcomes for cample kids for me kids.
>> Yeah.
>> Thank you.
>> No.
So, uh, yes. So, we're in agreement
that, um, content interventionist,
interventionist, counselor to student
ratio, right now we're running at 140,
400, 1 to 450 in Austin ISD. You really
best practice, one to one, one to 300.
Uh, what you all had to do here in
raising funds for interventionists is
not something that should happen, right?
That's the honest truth. And schools
that can raise do exactly what Maplewood
did. That happens all across the city.
But there are lots of schools that can't
do that.
And so as a system, what we know is that
in 2022 and 2023, we had instructional
coaches which really help us focus on
first teach, right? Educators coming to
the classroom getting what they need to
be academically to be successful. We um
didn't have them everywhere in Austin
ISTD. So what we said is let's use title
one dollars because we had some
remaining at the end of the 22 and 23
school year and let's fully fund uh
instructional coaches in Austin ISC
focusing on title one schools that had
not happened before in Austin IC. So we
made that change. Then we came back
around and said schools should not have
to fund raise to get a content
interventionist because that helps us
with interventions right to get students
back on grade level. you you said that
that's what we we agree as well but
right but it's but we didn't have that
in 2022 23 we didn't have that anywhere
in Austin ISD do you know that we did
not have that anywhere I had schools
like asking Matias can we trade a
librarian for instructional coach or a
content interventionist can I trade uh
you know assistant principal for these
for these other allocations it should
not be that way you should not have to
trade staff to get what you need for
your students to be successful so
So,
>> so
>> yeah. So, yeah. No, no, so I I
appreciate that question. So, that comes
down to you mentioned funding, title one
funding, and the way that works. So, in
Austin ISD, uh title one funding, the
way that it's currently uh um
distributed to the district is based on
the number of students who are
identified as economically
disadvantaged. Uh in Austin ISD, seven,
eight years ago, we were at 62 63%. We
are struggling right now to stay above
50%. Right? We are quickly going to
become a school district that has the
minority population be identified as
economically disadvantaged. That is very
very unique to urban school districts.
Most urban school districts, as I'm sure
you know, are 80, 85, 90% economically
disadvantaged. So what that means is
that your title one dollars
are going down, right? That is
happening. Every single year, we have
lost more and more title one dollars.
When you tie that to the fact that the
federal government is going to move away
from title one grants and go to block
funding, that number is going to go even
further down. And so we as a school
district have to figure out how do we
find the funds within our existing
system based on stable revenue to ensure
that every school gets what they need,
right? Instructional coaches, content
interventionist, the counselor to
student ratio, whatever is required for
their for that school, for those
students. So
>> I mean
So, we have staffing plans uh and ratios
in our um
uh in attachment I think 11 of or nine
of the uh two October 3rd. And what we
talk about in there is what it's going
to look like at our schools. Um
specifically those that have turnaround
plans because those are the ones that
have the highest need. just you know
that that's his honest truth. Uh two um
where we have large program moves and
then three where we have moves like
this. So we want to get to a place where
we can offer those types of ratios
everywhere. But the reality is they're
they're not going to be everywhere now
because the student population they're
not now but that's the whole thing is I
don't have the resources to do it. I
just don't.
>> Matias can I can I interject real quick?
So I want to just make sure everyone
understands kind of the you started
talking about how the title funding
works. Yeah.
>> So the title funding comes to the
district based on the percent of
students that we have that are economic.
It's we as a district get to decide then
how to allocate those. So each year we
establish what's going to be that um
threshold that a campus needs to meet in
terms of their economically
disadvantaged population to be granted
some of a a portion of those funds. Last
year we the number was at 50%. We used
to actually be able to keep that number
lower because we had more title funds.
So I think when I started maybe seven,
eight years ago, it was at 40, you only
needed 40% to be getting it. And so
every year we have to make that
calculation. If you lower the the
percent threshold and each campus gets
fewer dollars, right? If you raise the
threshold, fewer campuses get more of
those title dollars. But one thing I've
talked to um Christy Fox, she's um
manages our state and federal grants um
is that we'll have to go through that
process this year just like we do every
year. But then looking at specifically
special situations where you have a
campus that was almost completely
economically disadvantaged population,
but now if the combined population
isn't, how do we make sure that they
that those supports don't just get
erased? And so again, we get to decide
how we allocate those title funds and we
we already have an eye on specifically
those situations where the population
might bring them below the threshold,
but that we still are going to say, you
know what, we're going to make sure that
they get those allocations.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> Um it is absolutely a commitment that we
will look at it. So the um
so the Can I clarify? So every school
like like our superintendent said that
has a tap is already going to be
allocated extra resources. So some of
them are going to get that on top of it,
right? And so if they're already getting
that, that's going to say, okay, they're
getting this extra 800,000. that means
that we can maybe lower the amount of
title that kind of lowering that
threshold so that we can make special um
accommodations for these types of
scenarios. So I can promise you that it
will be a conversation. I'm not going to
be I'm not the person that can promise
you that what decision will be made, but
I can be I can assure you that extra
allocations would be given to make sure
that the need is met. And I think you
could speak more to that. Well, I I
think your your question is a is a is
one that I I think is an important one
and that is the way that we get at that
staffing allocations um plan is to
understand what is going to happen. Um
you know that's why in our staffing plan
there are five different scenarios and
each one of them has their own plan and
we will not arrive at that plan until
our principles are together until our
staff are working through it till we
have other people in the room. If I just
came and said it's going to be this,
this, or this, that is not necessarily
going to meet the needs of that
community. We know that. And so, we're
kind of in this weird spot where I've
committed to going through the work.
We're committed to having unique plans
for each move, but the details of those
plans are not going to be set until
y'all's voice, principal voice is
included in that process. That's just
how we that's how we operate. I I I just
want you to know that's how if we came
here and said this is the plan, it
wouldn't work either. So, that's that's
why we go through that process.
>> Okay. I see three hands up. So, I'm
going to take these three questions and
then we're going to go to the next um
comment card question.
>> Hi, Tracy Dunlap. I'm a teacher here,
pre-K teacher and a leader with
Education Austin. We've met
Superintendent Sigura. And I want to ask
a follow-up question about staffing
allocations. First of all, I want to
start off by saying having a meeting at
8 a.m. on a Wednesday disenfranchises
staff from being able to participate in
this process.
Okay, this was the the communication was
that this was for staff and community,
but at 8:00 in the morning, most staff
are in their classrooms serving our
students. So, well, it disenfranchises
some parents that have to work as well,
but um focusing on staff here, I have
not yet heard a commitment that all
staff will be able to move.
>> So, so here's the thing. Um, I keep
hearing that a school is more than a
building. Okay, I agree with that. But a
big part of what a school is is the
staff that take care of the kids.
[applause]
And there won't be room at the
consolidated campus for everybody from
Campbell and everybody from Maplewood to
all stay together with our community.
And I'm mostly concerned, you know, I
have a contract as a teacher and whether
it's at Campbell or somewhere else, if I
want to stay in AISD, I feel pretty
confident that I'll have a job. But we
have classified employees here that have
been working here for 25 or 30 years.
and what happens to our custodians, our
cafeteria workers.
To be told 2 years from retirement after
25 years of service at a campus that you
can't move with your school community
and you maybe don't even have a job is
devastating.
So, I'm looking for a guarantee that
anybody from this campus who works here
who wants to go to Campbell has that
place.
So, the last half of that question where
you said that um classified staff um are
are worried about um not having a job.
I've been very clear the entire time.
Educators, professionals, classified
staff, custodial staff, food service
staff, these these individuals are in
many ways like the foundation of our
system. They really are. I you know that
about me. I I get frustrated when I hear
that that's not some a group of people
that we care about or supporting. We are
very much thinking about them. And I
have said that they will have a job in
Austin ISC as I've said.
So
I cannot guarantee I cannot guarantee
that's what you're asking for. I will I
can't guarantee.
>> That's I and I appreciate that. But
that's not you know I can't guarantee
that because at the end of the day look
at the student teacher ratio. When you
have a combined student group you're not
there's going to be some adjustment.
There just is. And I don't want to sit
here and guarantee something. Now, our
intent is have everybody that we can
work and get into the new school
together. We want familiar faces. That
is how this plan can be successful. I'm
not going to go and we're not going to
hire anybody outside of these
communities. That's not going to happen.
This communities first. We work through
a plan. we figure out how to get
everybody over a given the student
population the allocations, but I can't
guarantee that we'll have six custodial
staff when in every other school at that
size we'll have three or four. Like that
just that's just not a guarantee I can
give you. But I can guarantee that
they'll have a job. I can guarantee you
that they'll give us input and what they
want next in their future at Austin ISD.
And I can guarantee you that with that
information, we will ensure that it
matches as best as we can. And we've
said that every single time. That is
that is how it has to work. There's no
way I could guarantee that every single
person in both schools would remain. I
mean that's
>> so two principles.
>> I mean four I mean that that I mean
>> that's not so the principal. So that's
that's one of the that's one of the
efficiencies that's one of the that's
the honest truth. So when you think
about um how a principal's
administrative staff are allocated
within Austin ISD, you have a principal
for 150 kids, 200 kids, 240 kids, 500
kids, 600 kids, one principal like
that's the same,
>> right? And so
>> no, but that you just But I'm just
telling them going like administrative
staff that's front office staff as well,
right? That gets asked about all the
time. How
>> one of the things that we're trying to
do is become more efficient to reduce
cost. So how
>> we're trying to reduce cost and
earlier.
Okay. So, I'm going to go ahead and
bring us because we had said that we had
to let two other people go and then I'm
going to take a question from the
comment card and then I see you have
your hand up. Um, and I'll take the
gentleman in the back next and that's
about all I can keep in my brain.
Hi, my name is Carla. I have a
kindergartener and a second grader here.
Um, and to piggyback on to Miss Dunlap's
question, you're telling us that our
staff will not be whole and move over if
we consolidate with Campbell. You have
also said that the district will appoint
the new principal in December. the new
principal has a say in the staff it
takes over. Looking at a timeline that
likely won't happen until Q1, January,
February, March. You're also asking us
as Maplewood community to enroll in AISD
at that same period. Talking to all of
my friends, I know a 100% for a fact
many people are already looking outside
of this district, looking at charters,
looking at private.
I also know that AISD is having a
problem with attrition. We are losing
students left and right. losing students
from an A campus with a dedicated staff
and TEA just said we're number four
elementary school in Texas. Losing this
community,
sorry, by academic growth standards. um
losing this community and having us sign
up elsewhere out of it because we won't
know what we're signing up for when
you're expecting us to sign up is a huge
disservice. And also, Matias, I was at
your meeting for East Austin Schools
last night. You consistently said, "We
want to protect brown and black
students." Combining Maplewood with
Campbell, a historically black campus,
is not supporting that argument.
So uh the first thing is
I am very aware
I am very aware that the type of harm
that can be introduced if we don't go
through a process that transitions
Campbell period the reality is Campbell
is very very small very small there are
lots of empty seats in this
And so to address this solution as a
whole, something has to move the and as
I said before and I and and there were
if if we went a different way and took
Campbell, moved them into Maplewood, how
much of their culture would be preserved
if you distribute if can I can I can I
>> can I
>> folks can we let can we let him complete
a thought and then if there's follow-up
questions I'm happy to come back around.
So or you distribute right you break you
break the school up some students go
north some students go east some like
black shear is already receiving
students there there's not a lot of
opportunity to ensure that that
community stays together if we go
through with this solution with enough
planning time then we have a better
chance of doing it than a more than what
potentially could be a more disruptive
way which I just described there aren't
lots of options here so the other thing
I'll say is um the question I I
understand that that the um the comment
uh or the question around um
ultimately uh that was earlier around
staff participating you being a staff
person uh we were very clear and and you
will see meetings I'm not sure if one
has occurred already with just staff so
when we have these meetings we really
try to follow the lead of the community
kind of what works best no time is ever
going to be perfect. I so I apologize
that it's at 8 a.m. That's not, you
know, I'm I'm trying to make this work.
It could I I will show up wherever you
want me to show up. That's the honest
truth. Uh we are going to have
additional meetings with staff so we can
hear staff voice and can and make sure
that it is clear we have that dialogue
and support them through this process.
Um so I just want you to know that if it
hasn't happened, it will happen. We're
going through just like we're having
these meetings. Um and you know, I'm
happy to look at alternatives,
refinements. The one thing that you said
that I want to talk about is hiring of
the principal, right? So, in the
milestone schedule I I shared with
trustees um several weeks ago was that
in December, we want to make sure that
we identify who the principal is. And we
wanted to do that so that we had enough
of a runway to have that principal work
with the schools, begin to go through
the staffing process, so earlier in the
process, our families would know. if I
wait till even January, right, I lose
about four to five weeks in a 12-week
registration process. And so it does
even, you know, even delaying it weeks
really harms our ability to support any
family transition. We don't want
families to leave Austin ISD. We
absolutely don't. But right now, I don't
have the ability to fund us and stay
whole and and solvent for years to come.
I just don't. And so that puts us in a
very difficult spot. But that's why we
have these timelines set. Um, you know,
there's going to be dialogue with our
trustees this evening in a work session.
We'll refine, we'll improve. This
feedback is also very helpful. I'm
excited to see what plans that y'all may
be brought forward. But that's why we
wanted those timelines to be done that
way.
>> Real quick, um, and I'm going to let you
follow up, but um, we also do have a
little bit more detail. We're trying to
figure out the timeline of the
enrollment cycles. We're kind of
changing the rounds that we've
historically done. So, if you'd like, we
can kind of talk a little bit about
that. Did you want to ask your follow-up
first or Okay.
>> I just feel like that didn't address my
question. So like you're saying here
you're going to select a principal then
you can't select the staff until after
that. So it's going to be January. So I
appreciate your answers but I feel like
it didn't address our confidence in
enroll reenrolling and AISD moving
forward.
>> Yeah. Let's talk real quick about the
timeline for enrollment.
>> Hi. Good morning everyone. Uh previously
I introduced myself as the executive
director of campus engagement and campus
and family engagement. Uh but that means
I have the pleasure of serving uh the
enrollment, parent support and um
engagement teams uh along with student
attendance. Uh and so we are um working
through the transition planning um and
there are several changes to the system.
And so the first thing to know is that
you will have from approximately not set
in stone midFebruary um until midappril
to make decisions as a family about
where you're going to choose to enroll.
So there will be time um throughout uh
the process so that things will be more
firm, things will be more known, things
will be more understood uh before you
are um asked to make kind of that final
decision.
Yeah. Um so we uh can't control their
timeline, right? And um our timeline is
constrained by uh you know different
factors. So we are getting things moving
um as early as we can. We know that this
year there's going to be a little a
transition and then moving forward there
will be permanent timelines that'll be
put into place. Um in general uh what we
will have moving forward is that um the
early registration period the round one
will be for um special programs uh
things that are districtwide um type
programs. And so no longer will anyone
feel like they have to jump on it in
November in order to uh secure a spot.
And so round two general registration
will start in the second semester and
that will um uh so that is how we will
be able to um accommodate everyone and
within the system every family will
still have choices. So um you will be
able to rank uh the choices. If you are
here at Maplewood and um you are zoned
to Maplewood, you will be presented with
Campbell if everything goes forward.
um as your zoned campus. If you are
transferred to Maplewood and you rank
Campbell first in your um rank of uh
campuses, then um that will be
automatically granted. However, you
you're not required to do that as well.
And just to clarify on what you were
asking about the timelines. So in light
of understanding charter schools
timelines, if you recall when we started
the enroll Austin system, that's when we
started introducing the enrollment
opening in November. Um obviously the
timeline that we're on with this process
prevents us from opening that early this
year. But moving forward, we would
resume that practice of starting in
November. Um, okay. I have you back here
and I was gonna come up to you and the
gentleman in the kind of puffer jacket.
Hi, I'm Libby. I have two kids here. Um,
nice to meet you. Thank you for being
here. Um, I just wanted to go back
because the first question was about
academics and why are you closing
Maplewood and we got in a lot of
different tangents and I just am hoping
you could say in like one sentence
why because I I heard you say like
that's inefficiency.
We're efficient. We're we're we cost 21%
less than the average.
you
you mentioned Campbell and the equity
there and the special culture and not
wanting to move um you know data you
mentioned data about not wanting to move
underserved kids. We have just as many
underserved kids here as at Campbell.
Um and so can you just say in like a
sentence why are you closing this
amazing efficient A-rated school?
So the
>> that's why I'm that's why I'm taking my
time.
>> I I don't want to.
>> Matias, it might be helpful to look at
>> No, I'm gonna respond. I I think it's
important to respond. Um
yes, Maplewood is efficient. There's no
doubt. Uh CA Campbell also is very
small. This is two of 116 schools that
we have. So I I I I don't want to
not to argue that you're not efficient
or that you're not doing great things.
That's not that's not what we're we're
doing. I am trying desperately to ensure
that every school has the ability to be
to get to their students what Maplewood
is able to give to their students. And I
cannot do that without hang
I I understand this is this is the
challenge I have with 70,000 students.
We are running a budget deficit. I do
not have the ability to fund everything
that we need to to ensure that our
students get what they need. And given
where our schools are, they're fixed.
Given where our families live, that's
fixed. There are limited opportunities
we have within the 116 to to improve
efficiencies, to find dollars, to
allocate elsewhere in the district to
become the district where every student
gets what they need. That's the honest
truth. It it's not Maplewood specific.
We understand how great this community
is. We we I understand that.
>> So, Matias, I think it would
>> cost you more. I would like I would like
to give a little bit more like technical
detail to the question they were asking
because I think that you're kind of
going like philosophically. Um if I
pulled up this slide because it kind of
shows there are many things as Matias
started out saying that we're trying to
solve for across the district, right?
But there's a lot of vast differences in
our city in terms of what when we did
that rubric what the misalignments were,
right? And so we have to look at things
in regions because we're looking at
opportunities of schools that are
adjacent to one another, right? we've
already we've decided we're not going to
be trying to transfer students to school
to pass several schools to get to
another school, right? Um and so this
map kind of showed like certain areas we
have too many seats, certain areas we
have not enough seats. And so you have
to really when we think about what h
what we decided for Maplewood and I'm
going to ask um Miss French to come up
and kind of talk specifically about what
we looked at like what are the
challenges in this area of all the
schools what are the constraints and
things that we needed to solve around
and how we it's not like we like we only
looked at this option right we looked at
all of the different configurations that
we could do and landed on this as being
the most feasible um that addresses the
most issues with the least disruption
which might seem like you know difficult
to believe But if you look at some of
the other options, it introduces other
problems. So I want to ask Miss French
to talk a little bit.
>> All right. Hi. And I have just going to
stay seated because I'm looking at my
computer and if there's follow-up
questions. So
when closing schools, no one wants to do
that. It's terrible. I think we all
agree we don't want to be doing this.
But knowing that that is our path
forward to get to where we need to be
efficiently as a district, that is kind
of our starting point, right? And the
task at hand.
I'm here with you. I get it. Um I will
say so we had to then look at okay how
can we make it least disruptive as
possible to do this hard thing and the
one thing we could control in some
instances and this is not the case
everywhere but if we had the ability to
keep a whole community together and I
hear y'all about staff and I think we've
addressed that but the students we've at
least addressed it the best we can
today. So the keeping students together
if we can do that we want to do that and
this was an instance where we could. So
that is why when we're closing Oak
Springs they are going into Black Share
there was space for both communities to
stay together. That is why when we look
at Campbell and Maplewood both
communities can stay together in
Campbell's building. We did look at
other solutions. We can't fit all of Oak
Springs, all of Campbell, all of
Blackshere into one building. we can't
fit like we looked at well what what
what about Blandon that's nearby what
can we do there but that is a large
school with a large resident population
and it's um it's a bigger school and
that is just one of the facts that we
have in our district and in our building
inventory and then when we look at you
know further northeast because we again
we look at everything as a system um we
have you know Sanchez is a you know we
have these we that's kind of a separate
I don't want to go into that we'll talk
through that with that community and
we'll talk through the board meeting
board tonight but there's and we have
modernized buildings throughout the
district and we have a lowered reside
population. So, I'm just we've spent
countless hours looking and iterating
and trying to find a solution that
provided the least amount of impact and
when we had the ability to keep
communities together, that is what we
prioritized here and that is what got us
to the solution that we're talking
through today. So,
>> I'm happy to do that. Um, and then, um,
I do want to make sure that I get to the
two people that I said I would call on.
So, I'll let me go through the next
comment card and then we'll get to
people. And I appreciate that.
We are breezing through the time.
>> Um, okay. What happens to Mabel in this?
I think this be for Miss Cardinus. What
happens to Maplewood's dual language
program? Will it move intact to Campbell
and how will admission access work? Will
siblings continue to have preferred
access to the program? Okay, thank you
so much for that question. So, we heard
Mr. Sagura talk a little bit about um
just where emergent bilingual students
live, right? And where our dual language
programs are. So, dual language, as you
know, is a bilingual education model.
The intent is to serve emergent
bilingual students. In Austin ISD, we
want others to participate. So, we have
um locations where students can do that,
where we have a mixture of non-emergent
bilingual participation and emergent
bilingual participation.
I know this campus can do hard things. I
remember visiting this campus when
principal no was just starting off and
we had lots of conversations and look at
where you are now, right? So, I know
this campus can do hard things. Thinking
about that,
thinking about that, um, we do want to
acknowledge that you have a dual
language program here. We also want to
acknowledge that you have a tiny number
of emergent bilingual participating. You
have uh 14% emergent bilingual
participants in your dual language
program. But we also want to the
proposal is to move the strand that you
have now into Campbell and then start to
phase it out, right? Just because there
are not enough emergent bilingual
students either here at Maplewood or in
the Campbell area. But we do respect,
right, what you've done with your dual
language program. And so that is uh the
direction that we'd like to move in.
That means that your current strand
would move. we would not be bringing new
students into the dual language program.
Um, and again, it would just roll up and
then roll out. We also want you to know
that there are other dual language
programs here in the area, right? So,
you also can, if you want to apply to
Bllandon has a dual language program,
Harris has a dual language program,
Andrews, Sanchez, Pickle. There are
other campuses in the area that also
have dual language programming.
Thank you so much. I'm gonna do one more
comment card. Um, and just so you know,
we did schedule this till 9:30, so we
actually have about a half hour. Um,
yeah, a followup to the dual language
question.
>> I'm I'm curious to know about the staff.
How are they going to be incentivized to
stay if we're winding down their
employment?
>> In in this particular um instance, and
again, I can't make guarantees. some not
talent strategy. But in this particular
instance, Campbell does not have a dual
language program and you do and you have
the staff right now. Um, so with the
program moving, we will need bilingual
certified teachers in that in that
program.
It will be it will be
>> Can you repeat the question because I
don't think that picked up on the mic
for the interpretation.
>> The follow-up question.
Mhm. Yes, it will be a phase out program
just simply because there are not enough
emergent bilingual students between
Maplewood and Campbell and we really are
trying to again as Mr. Matias said I
mean Mr. Mr. Siguda said we we also need
to see so just so you'll know um just
kind of big big picture I wrote this
down every year every school district
has to submit their number of ESL
waiverss and bilingual exceptions. What
that is is those are teachers who are
working on their certification but are
not yet certified with their ESL or
their bilingual. So Austin ISD uh this
year is submitting 438
waiverss and exceptions. Um there 161 of
those are for bilingual positions. So
that means we have that number of
classrooms that are are being served by
teachers that are working towards their
certification but do not have their
certification right now. So that just
kind of puts things in perspective when
we look citywide about how much uh our
bilingual certified teachers right need
to be in the areas where we have um
strong where we have emergent bilingual
students for strong programming. Okay.
The next question in the um comment card
was a one with multiple comments, but
we've covered already is that will
current Maple Maplewood transfer
students and their siblings be
automatically accepted? That was not
part of the original release draft, but
it is something that we are updating to
clarify.
>> Yes.
>> Yes,
>> it counts for all transfers even out of
district.
>> Say that question again. The
clarification
that that would be your option. That
would be the family's option. So, we
would we would have the trans the
students in the the question it was
around dual language and if a if there
was a student who is already I guess in
pre-k or kindergarten that was in the
program would that apply? If the student
is in the school, a siblings in the
school, third grade, and a student's
coming as a kindergartener, we would
automatically approve that transfer.
Now, the programming at that school is
really a decision for the family. We
have families right now that choose to
split their students up because one
school has a program, the school
doesn't. We would not be able to offer
necessarily that that um that pathway
because by board policy, we have to have
18 emerging bilingual students in the
school
>> um to actually to be per grade. Yeah. To
be able to actually
>> allocate the staff. So, there's this
kind of conflict that we run into. Um,
but we would trans we would
automatically approve the transfer if
you choose to to go to the new school.
>> Okay, next question back here.
>> Hello.
>> Appreciate you guys coming out. Um, I
think we need to set a baseline on what
this conversation is. So, from looking
at how you guys are talking about it and
this this is labeled as a draft. I think
it's become very clear to us here that
this is a draft in terms of the details
like the transfer details. This is very
clearly not a draft at the base part of
what your staff's recommendation is
going to be that Maplewood will be
merged with Campbell. Am I correct in
that? That that's going to be a
recommendation barring something
drastic. Staff's recommendation is not
going to change that Maplewood is going
to be merged into Campbell. Am I
correct?
>> So, it'll be my recommendation. So,
staffs, uh, there are still things that
we're going through. I mean, I'm not
going to sit here and say yes or no. I
will say that the fact that it's in this
plan, the fact that it got to this point
that there is a strong probability, but
we're going through it all. I'm I'm
getting comments, we're getting
feedback, we're getting comment where
we're going to have a discussion with
our trustees. At the end of the day, it
comes down to what do you exchange? You
know, what do you what what objective or
what goal do we have as a system that
doesn't get met if we don't do this or
what alternative exists, right? Because
we still have empty seats. We still have
a budget deficit. We still have lots of
things we have to consider. So no, we do
have a budget deficit in Austin ISD and
this is in Austin ISD. So yes, there is
a budget deficit
>> and yeah, and we don't need to talk
about the budget deficit and where that
came from and that yes, that's the
state's fault. It's not just the state's
fault, but we understand that you are
under a lot of pressure and we
understand that. But at the same point,
if you get yourself in the in a bigger
hole later because the decisions you
make now, that's not going to help
either. And we but the basic point is
okay, your recommendation is Maplewood's
merging. we can co we can concentrate on
talking to the trustees. You're
interested in hearing details and maybe
you'll change your mind.
>> And I'll just clarify. So Matias
mentioned at the beginning of the
meeting that we have a board meeting
tonight. We actually will be going
through all of the the themes that we
heard in the comment cards in the areas.
We're looking at different boundaries,
these transfer things, and there will be
some other discussion um some bigger
pieces to the plan that will be under
discussion. Um so that'll be a public
discussion this evening.
Hi, Adam Sparks, first grade parent. I'd
just like to say Oh, thank you'all. You
look very sharp this morning as well.
You look very good and I appreciate how
hard this is to do this. Um, I'd like to
get to the specifics of the issue, which
is you're proposing to close this school
in a one-month time period in November.
I was last here. Well, I I guess you're
very good at articulating what the
problem is for ASD, but we don't feel
confident that this group has the
solution because we're a month away.
We're a semester away from TA takeover,
the finances of the district are taking
us to a place where we might not have
any money soon. And so, the question is
not what the problem is. The question
is, is closing this school in a one-mon
time frame going to fix that problem?
And the answer to Carla's question was
the one sentence was why money. So, now
let me just back up for a second. I was
in this room six years ago when the last
time that AISD came and proposed this
consolidation and back then it was
because these windows weren't good and
they said that the ceiling was dripping
even though that it wasn't that we had
to be in a modernized building otherwise
our students couldn't learn well but now
we're the fourth highest in the state by
growth. We're full. We filled the you
know we didn't we didn't want the uh
portables that made our capacity got
high and put us on the top of the
rubric. But that's something that y'all
asked us to fill and then our principal
did that. She filled it. She got the
grades up. She did everything that was
asked of her.
And so the question is, why has there
been no conversation the last six years?
We've had six years to talk about what a
Maplewood Campbell conversation was look
like. We've had zero. There are no
answers on what academics will be there,
what programs will be there, which
culture will be there. You talk about
wanting to help the students at
Campbell. Y'all have not spoken to a
single parent at Campbell.
Is that true? That is true. And so to
say that this is for the students at
Campbell, but you haven't engaged them
once. They can fill out a comment card.
You haven't talked to them, you haven't
been there, you haven't worked with our
school communities, you haven't done any
of the leadership. And so when the
trustees are saying that the school
district's communication on this plan is
a failure, when people around the
district, when you have a room like
this, and here's the thing that trustee
Boswell said, 72 students leaving the
district cost the district a million
dollars. the number the thousands of
students that have gone to charter and
private schools since you last proposed
closing this school, millions of
dollars. And so the question is, what do
we save by closing Maple? Why why do it
in a month? There's no reason. I mean,
there's no other way to say that. They
haven't done the work. There's no reason
to close it in a month. Tea demands
something on the 20th. They just want to
get the money out for the month. So why
do we have to rush this into one month
to save how much? We were told here in
this room with your director of
operations that we would receive a
breakdown of how much money closing this
campus would receive. We've been told by
yourself. The trustees put it in their
notes and not only was that information
not given to them, they weren't even uh
responded to. Trusty Hunter was not
responded to in her request asking for
what was promised to us. So, we don't
know how much money is going to be
saved. It's going to help people in the
future. That that will all come in the
plan eventually once the school is
closed. The estimates are around a
million dollars. And if that is true,
that is one less than onetenth of 1% of
AISD's operating budget. And so the
question is, why must we rush all of our
children's future into a one-month plan
that does not have a plan? We saw the
plan. It was that one paragraph there.
That's all that they thought about uh at
least told us about or told either
school community about.
Why must that happen? For a million
dollars,
that's going to fix AISD.
What is the solution? Why is closing
this 72 people I mean let me just ask
how many people have looked at a charter
school or a uh private school since this
plan began.
>> Okay.
So is this going to help
or is this actually going to hurt?
Um, I'm just gonna go ahead and start
because I wanted to share something. We
actually did do kind of a some research
into do school closures save money and
there are plenty of instances where it
doesn't, right? Um, we know that in 2019
when we closed schools, we did save
money and then what we did was we we
planned with those school communities
and we said, "What extra investments do
they need?" And then the pandemic hit,
right? and a lot of those savings were
eaten up. Um, but it doesn't mean that
just because the funds that were freed
up were spent doesn't mean that it
didn't free up funds to put in other
places, right? But what a lot of what
you can see across the board, the kind
of consensus is that where the success
or failure lies is in the transition,
right? Is in supporting families in
getting information to families as
quickly as possible about what the
programs are. And so with the draft that
we're releasing on on Friday, we also
have started developing a framework for
those transition plans. So if anyone's
familiar with our CAT process, the
campus architectural teams where we
bring community together to talk about
planning for the a new facility or
improvements to a facility, it's going
to be a similar model to that where
we'll bring teams of folks together from
both communities to start going step by
step through what are all those
considerations? What are the
considerations for special education?
What are the considerations for
outreach? Doing block walks, phone
banking, meet and greets, all these
things that we can begin doing as soon
as we know, right? Um but until we and
and in a perfect world, if we had more
time, a lot of that work could have
started if we kind of but we need to
know a direction before we start
bringing before we start bringing folks
together because of the timeline that
we're on. The truth is in 2022 when we
built that bond, it was a two-year
process and we were at every single
school talking about what's working,
what's not, and it built one of the most
successful bond projects or programs,
right? Um I'm sorry, say that again.
>> Can we
need to
work in the next year? That's one year
of
excess.
>> So,
>> yeah. So, so, so this is a so this is a
an this is one of the things that we're
talking about now, right? Um, with our
trustees, I intend to bring it up
tomorrow. So, the the reality is will
the state take over our school district
next month? No. Means please, please,
that's you know, no. Um, are there real
risks that we're navigating? Yes. like
that. Those are very significant risks.
You said about why weren't you here the
last six years if you would have told me
in 23 that the state would not allocate
any funds. I I wouldn't have believed
you in 20 and 25. Well, I was here in
19. I remember that in 19. But think
about what happened since then. Think
about the pandemic. Think about the
change in the federal government. All
these things have compacted and I mean
added more pressure to our system. So,
so to your so to your specific question
like does does the vote for for
Maplewood and Campbell have to occur on
the same timeline? It is it is a
separate you have the programmatic
moves, you have the tap moves and you
have the consolidations which is what
this is. They are very different. The
one thing that I want to kind of
reinforce to our community is that we
have to stop going through huge
devastating changes. I also want time
for families to plan. I really, really
do. And so I don't want to wait till the
spring semester to take a vote. That's
not the case. Right.
>> So I would that's the question is is the
vote next November or is it you take a
vote now and then you don't do the
change until the following year. Right?
So those are two different things
because
>> why not get it all right?
I that's
>> so can I just I just want to put
something in pers can I put something in
perspective for you if let me just put
something in perspective
>> we are represented by people who rep
there's seven trustees that represent
seven parts of the district and then we
have two at large right um if we have
committed to doing something that is
districtwide I just want you to think
about what that what that feels like to
the communities that are that have to do
that are on a timeline right the
turnaround plans because those do have
to be voted on, right? And so if we were
to remove and our trustees have the
authority to do they can they could do
that, right? They could pull out the
ones that are not as pressed for time.
But which schools would that be? That
would be what? Breerwoods, Maplewood.
Trying to think
>> Valley is tied to a tap
>> because of wind, right? They're not.
>> So I think you have to understand that
that that
what that appears like is that certain
school communities are not affected
while other ones are affected.
>> I still
us
>> and I think that's a conversation our
trustees can have. Right.
>> The issue that's the answer the dollars
why does the school have to $1 million
and why won't we get those financials?
>> So it's not. No. So we're providing the
financials. Um I well we've we're going
to upload another version on the 30th
because
>> yeah because because one of the things
that so there's two competing things
here because there's a comment over here
from this gentleman that said all staff
go right well that that's not going to
show obviously any reduction in cost and
that's not how it would work.
>> Soion
there's no target amount. What it is is
as a system we have to find where we're
inefficient. There are two schools. It's
Campbell and Maplewood. It's not just
maple would be inefficient. It's the
fact that we have 140 students at one
school and
>> we have over 20,000 extra seats in
Austin ISD. That's I mean I I don't
know. I mean we that is that is much
larger than Moody.
>> Okay. It's not seven. This the student
the basic student a lotment is 6 thou
over $6,000. It's not 70 students.
>> All right. I'm going to call in three
more people. I'm going to do a comment
card, but I'm going to call in You'll be
after the comment card, then you'll be
next, and then I've seen you have your
hand right back there. Um, so the next
comment card, we might have already gone
over it. It's about the timeline. That's
what we've just been talking about. So,
I'm going to go ahead and bring it over
here.
>> Thank you so much. which I'm I'm not
going to say just because you know um so
as a parent who had the option at my
daughter is a transfer into Maplewood. I
had the option of choosing any school in
AIS to transfer her to. So that means I
had the option to choose to go to
Campbell or the option to come to
Maplewood. I chose Maplewood because of
its higher academic standards and I knew
that it had a a track record of
highquality education and that's where I
wanted my child to go. So my question
future forward thinking about should
this plan go through. What is your plan
to bring Campbell up to the highest
academic standard that Maplewood has
already proven that it can meet? Because
what it looks like, and I'm a lifelong
Austinite my entire life, and it seems
as though Campbell has been allowed to
languish
in lower scores in underperforming
systemically and and there's all these
code words running around here about
systemic harm and that sort of thing,
but what's the plan to make sure that if
a merger were to take place that the
Campbell students who are there have
access to the same
high academic standard that has already
been set here and that we don't let any
students languish.
>> Yeah, that's a
let me answer that first.
So the the first thing I would say is um
we're not starting from scratch. Just to
be honest, the last two and a half
years, yes, in 2023 you had 30 schools
that fail were failing. 24 you had 29,
25, you have 23, right? There are so
many systems in Austin ISD that were not
in place two and a half years ago. Uh we
didn't have aligned curriculum. And
that's the honest truth, M. I mean, I'm
that is the honest truth. We had
different levels of rigor. We had
different expectations for black and
brown students. We It's in the data. we
can see this and so for us as a system
the first thing we needed to do is to
figure out do we have an understanding
of where our students are on the are
they on on grade level or are they not
that's MTSS multi-ter systems of support
which spent we spent the last 18 to 24
months putting into the system the
countless hours of professional
development so now our educators and our
principles understand and and clearly
like recognize what students need and
when but we didn't have the resources to
deploy if we have 40% of the student
population at a campus needing tier two
or tier three interventions
we didn't have the curriculum and we
didn't have the content interventionist
to actually deploy the curriculum or and
provide the instruction. So now in 2024,
we went we passed a tax rate election.
We got those resources in place now. And
so we're tracking for the first time and
as far as I can tell looking back years
and years and years, we actually have a
school district and not a district of
schools because what has happened is we
I'm not going to speak about any
specific school, but we did not have the
academic focus. Our principles and
leaders were not academic leaders. And
what was happening was we were asking PR
teachers to go and get professional
development right over here at central
office. And then at some point in the
semester, we'd come back and say, "Hey,
how's this going to go through
observations?" And what was it happening
in real time? Was that coaching, that
support? And if a student needed to get
on grade level, we didn't have the staff
in place or the curriculum in place. So
that is all in place now. So as you've
seen, and I know that many of you all
probably have been tracking our
accountability, it is moving. Early
literacy numbers are through the roof.
early numery numbers are through the
roof. We're going in the right
direction. I fully expect all of our
campuses to have what they need to be
academically successful. And here's the
other thing. Two years ago, we
implemented a sort um support and
resource index and we said, "Okay, those
schools that have additional needs need
to be prioritized in how we hire. they
be prioritized in um the way that we
engage the way that we respond to bu um
operating I mean uh oper uh building
operations uh tickets like everything
needs to be prioritized in a way to get
them where they need to be and it's
moving so I have my expectation is that
the rigor will be there it's already
moving that we have an aligned
curriculum that we're doing things
together we've st we've stabilized so
many things across the district we're 97
half% staff now attrition rate between
title one title one schools is below 2%
it 22% two years ago. So I feel
confident that when we plan together,
you our students at any school in Austin
ISD will have what they need to be
successful. And so we're not starting
from zero. We've been starting that work
and we talk about it all the time.
There's been lots of presentations about
it, which is why I feel confident that
if we just can keep doing what we are
doing, find resources. I I did not think
we would be here in 23 or in 25.
Honestly, nothing shifted and the
pressure only increased.
Well, so
>> so but that that's
that that's the whole thing is like we
have to do it together like the planning
I can tell you the framework I we we
just I just shared with you all the
things we're doing school by school the
curriculum all the inter like all of
those things what you're asking for is
what do you what is going to happen when
these schools come together specifically
right that requires the principles the
staff have everybody coming together and
planning. That's what's required, which
is why we're not going to make a
decision in the spring semester.
I've overseen magnet. I mean, I've
overseen mergers for sure.
>> Norman Norman Sim, I mean, I I don't
want to get into that debate. I I've
overseen mergers for sure in Austin ISD.
Norman
Um, so I just learned that we actually
have some representatives from Campbell.
So if the folks I've already called on
can hold tight, I want to make sure we
create space for them.
>> So I actually want to speak together
with Liz. Um, Liz is the PTA president
here and her and I are also friends as
well. Um,
I'm the PTA president of Campbell. Uh, I
think a lot of people in this room know
my face. I don't know you guys' face
because we have not had a meeting with
you at our school.
>> Yeah. So, I want to give Liz space after
myself, but I do want to touch on one
thing just because I'm going to always
defend Campbell. Uh, the last question
was about how we will are we going to
hold our students to the standard that
they hold Maplewood parents. I can
answer that question and this is the
only positive that will come probably
from this is actually our students our
lowest income students do score higher
than most in the district. So that is
actually um something we're very proud
of and something that actually our
lowest income students do sky score
higher than the the students here and
our highest students uh I mean our
students with the highest income also
have gifted intelligent programs as
well. So that's just doesn't paint the
full picture of our school which sort of
reiterates the point that we don't have
enough school. But uh I'm going to
continue. So when I listened to you
speak, you talked about a thoughtful
transition and yet we have not had a
meeting at our school with you guys. Um
and as we know this will affect equity.
And so listening to you guys talk about
equity uh without hosting a meeting with
the people of color that do attend
Campbell Schools, it it should be
borderline embarrassing to use that
word. It's almost inappropriate.
Our families didn't even know about the
consolidation until after the the draft
plan was uh was started. Um we know
historically black and brown families
tend to be the least considered in these
conversations. They take the longest
time to mobilize as low socioeconomic
families often do everywhere, not just
in AISD. And we all do know that. AISD
knows that. They talk a lot about
diversity and equity. With that being
said, our families didn't know until
this plan was already proposed. And then
we had a short turnaround time. We did
have a meeting with Trusty Hunter. We
had a lot of questions. We did get more
of a turnout than we would typically get
for these things. But I had to hope that
I would have the space and I wanted to
give the Maplewood parents the space to
speak. But we have not been heard and
it's nice that you guys get to hear me
here, but uh we had to find out through
Trusty Hunter that this meeting was even
happening. Um so you talk about pushing
out families. Uh 40% of our students
transfer in. We've spoken to those
families. They transfer in because it is
primarily a historically black school.
those students when they are outnumbered
by white students we cannot say that
they will transfer in which once again
brings back the point of attrition. So
planning for attrition of black and
brown families is a wild way to start
this. Uh we also talk about transfers.
Uh we have asked our trustee to get a
guarantee from you that legacy families
will also be guaranteed transfers. Um
because that goes beyond siblings. Um we
have family we have alumni that have
showed up uh to all of our meetings. uh
the ones that Yeah, we didn't we didn't
see you at um we talk about immigration
uh and our federal government and us not
having as many uh students um coming
into our schools. Um but our students
actually a lot of them speak Pasha. Um
so it's not actually uh it's not the
same English as a second language issues
that the other schools face. But with
that being said, this dual language
program that students are going to be
grandfathered into is going to show up
at Campbell and our students won't have
the act have access to that. So, I'd
like that guaranteed as well that our
students will have access to that
program. Uh, you said that dual language
will phase out at Campbell. Is that
correct? Uh, why? So, that will show up
at our school and our our students won't
have access to that. So, once again, our
students are going to lose. Uh and then
we uh yeah, we we were talking about
interventionists. If a lot of these
families that did raise their hands that
can afford charter schools and afford
private schools don't attend our school
and we are to lose the funds allocated
for interventionists, they were able to
raise the funds for their own
interventionists. We were provided that
through title one are once again now
we're running into the issue of how will
we afford that? And I know we're
supposed to hold on to a promise, but I
don't know how trustees can make these
decisions without them actually being
locked in because if those families
don't attend and we don't have the
funding for it, where are they going to
come from? Because our school scoring
the way that it does is based on these
things and specifically around our
culture. We are not an F school. All
statistics point to the fact that we
should be an F school given our low
income status. Um, and then yeah, uh, I
definitely want to, uh, iterate the fact
that, you know, I can't speak for all of
Campbell, though, uh, you know, we have
not, as far as PTA, we have the same
parents that show up all the time, and
we need time to mobilize our
communities. Um, and we again haven't
had a meeting, and I don't think I'm
going to see you guys before Friday at
our school. So,
Hi, I'm Liz and I'm the PTA co-president
here at Mipplewood. And Ken and I have
actually been having a lot of
conversations um in throughout this
whole process because we are very aware
of our communities being impacted by
this consolidation. And we are having
conversations of what that transition
plan will look like. We've been having
conversations of the negative impact it
will have on our communities and we just
want to make sure that we as we're
recognizing that if this consolidation
happens Campbell student body and
culture will shrink and our the
conversation we've been having is that
Campbell's belief and
frustration is that Campbell will become
Maplewood. the campus is going to be
brand new for Maplewood as well. So, we
just want to make sure that there's
specific concrete measures in place um
and that the district has will be
implementing to ensure that the needs of
Campbell's current largely economically
disadvantaged families are being
prioritized and protected throughout
this process, including their cultural
programs and their title one status. And
additionally, how will the district
ensure that MAP's academic achievement
is maintained, honored, and protected,
especially with the staff who have been
a very huge part of that. So, we have
very two different goals. We just don't
understand how this is going to work.
Understand that the funding needs to be
there. You guys need to save those
dollars.
Why couldn't the boundaries go the other
way?
Can you explain what you mean by the
other way real quick?
>> Oh, I see. So, like I got it. Got it.
Yeah.
>> Did we you kind of already spoke to that
a little bit or do we want to
>> Can you speak a little bit to why? So,
it sounds like the question is why
wouldn't you combine Lakshir and
Campbell? Is that or Oak Springs?
Oh, Oak Springs and um uh No, not you. I
think it was you Black Oak Springs to
Black Share is in the current plan,
which you're I guess that when you say
the other way, you're saying Oak Springs
and Campbell. Is that what you're
>> Oh, Blackshire and Campbell.
>> Yeah. So,
>> there there aren't as many as you I
mean, there are lots of there's schools
that are around each other, but they
don't all fit. And
Got it.
>> Understood. Yeah.
>> Got it.
So folks, I want to make sure that we
kind of
>> Yeah.
So, I want to make sure that we respect
because I think that they had some
questions that we still haven't answered
and I want to make sure we address that.
Um, I think that possibly Rachel's
because y'all submitted I'm assuming
that that plan was part of some of those
questions that y'all had about the
options that were proposed. So, I'll let
Rachel maybe talk a little bit about
some of the constraints, what might what
is possible, maybe isn't possible. Um,
as far as getting to Campbell, like I I
just will say I do feel disappointed in
our in myself and in the organization
that we haven't been able to get there
yet, and I appreciate you being here
today, and we we absolutely are going to
make that happen. There are there are
lots of schools that we haven't made it
to yet, right? Um it is is not a
timeline that I would have picked if if
I were to say how to get through this in
a really perfect thoughtful way, right?
Um that's just the reality. Um we
haven't gotten to a lot of the campuses
that have their programs um that are
going to be made wall to wall, but we
are working through to get there and we
are happy to prioritize making it to
Campbell and we recognize that that is
something that needs to happen and we
wish could have happened sooner.
>> I don't know who's saying my name.
>> So
>> Oh, okay.
Yes.
>> Yes.
>> So, thank you for that. If you've
reached out, I apologize if I've missed
that. I have been in communication with
Miss Barbara who coordinated that and we
have had conversations about bringing
these communities together. just hasn't
gotten on the calendar yet, but we are
going to have those conversation.
>> Sorry, I just I just want to jump in.
Hi, I'm Staca Pascal. I'm the director
of strategic planning and organizational
effectiveness. I work with Dr. Lewis and
we are a part of what's called the
bridge team. And so our focus has been
looking at the humans at the center of
this impact. And so we're thinking
through and planning and already being
responsive in providing support as we
are going through this consolidation
process. I wanted to speak to what you
named. Yes, there has not been a
fullfront district presence, but I have
engaged in conversations with principal
Moore. I've also engaged in
conversations with alumni members from
Campbell. So there is background work
that is happening. Um, I've been in
conversations with Miss Barbara Corver
Spears to ensure that I am fully
thinking through with my team all of the
ways in which we need to be prepared if
this vote goes through. So, I I do want
to name that those things are not lost
on me. Um, we are working together as a
team to think through how fear is going
to show up and impact the identity of
our children. And so um I just wanted to
name that. The second thing that I
wanted to speak to is one of the ways
that we are engaging with communities is
in smaller pockets. So there is the the
massive uh show that's happening.
So I didn't speak to parents at
Campbell. That's the point. Uh, so I
went into the adults that are a part of
what's happening at Campbell because
what I didn't want to do was to bring
everyone into a space and it didn't
happen. So I began in how do we put in
the framework that we're building those
considerations that might not be a part.
And so I I just wanted to name that. So
how did I what?
So one thing that was really important
was holding on to the culture that came
built through their uniform policy
through the fine arts and so thinking
through what does that mean? So that was
one of the pieces that we talked about
and looked at how do we ensure that
Campbell's identity doesn't become lost
in the merger. So those are things that
we have. We've looked at processing
circles. We've looked at morning meeting
prompts that could be a part of talking
through how do students feel and how are
they impacted in the possibilities of
this change. So those are some examples
of how it came into the framework. The
other thing I wanted to speak to um with
the PTA presidents we are so grateful
that you guys are coming together and
having these conversations and as Ally
named we will improve in how we engage.
We have had missteps, right? So, we're
acknowledging that. I don't want you to
think that anyone is being dismissive of
the possibilities of harm that could
come. So, I just wanted to take a moment
and say that. I'm going to pass it back.
I appreciate that you didn't growl at me
and you gave me some smiles. And I'm
just going to invite us all into like a
collective breath because the passion we
have here in the room is because we love
our children and we want what's best for
our children. And I get that. My why is
deeply rooted in my son's experience
here in Austin ISD. I wanted him to be
able to go to any school and a teacher,
a principal of whomever see him for the
potential of what he could be, not a
statistic that they thought he was. So I
I I want you to know these things are
not lost at all. There are people
extremely passionate about ensuring that
kids have access to
educators who see them and encourage
them and push them even when they are
falters in the resources that are
available.
>> Thank you. So, we are running out of
time and our superintendent does have
another engagement um in 30 minutes and
it's about 20 minutes away. Um I want to
just touch on the what another I skipped
a few questions that have already been
discussed but this one hasn't come up
yet. Um what is the plan and timeline
for closed campuses including potential
sale or repurposing? And will
playgrounds stay open to neighborhoods?
>> Okay, move on to that one. Got it. Let's
see. All right, that was the last one we
had prepared. So, and I had called on
you, I know. So I'm going to let you
have the last question.
>> Yeah, there are just a few threads to
follow up on. One is if there is such a
concern about preserving the culture of
Campbell as well as Maplewood, what
about options for citing prek at
Campbell? What about options for citing
the headquarters of creative action at
Campbell? It seems like the problem that
we have here is an inefficient use of a
large building. And because there is an
inefficient use of a large building, you
have to shut down the fourth highest
growing academic school in the state
and it just it doesn't follow for me.
And this is a very, as you said, this is
kind of a clean consolidation. I
understand some of the other
consolidations you're talking about
involve multiple schools and a lot of
complicated pieces. This is one where
you could just take this consolidation
off the list, leave everything else the
same, keep your same timeline, and just
reconsider whether there is a way to
utilize the space at Campbell for
something that would benefit their
community and generate the dollars that
we need.
So,
so we do take that approach and
throughout AISD and other schools as
well. I will tell you that there aren't
enough partners. There aren't enough. We
we we tried to do that.
>> Trust I I I appreci
I
>> I I this is what we've do been doing.
I've been filling up schools. You can go
to many schools and see all the partners
that we have. It is not that simple.
Well, at at the end of the day, it's not
just the operational cost of the
building. It's the administrative cost
of running two two schools that could
collectively run together that so it's
both. It's not just the water and
energy. That's not just that because
that would solve part of it, but we
still have a tons of space in Austin
ISD. It's the other half as well. And
so, I do I do hear you. I understand.
Um, and I I do appreciate the comment.
>> Exactly. This is a unique situation.
This is a unique situ. This is in my
knowledge the only situation where
you're moving a very large community
that has been, you know, accountability
ratings are what they are. They're
flawed, but has been an extremely
successful community in this place. It's
walkable. We've presented y'all with a
lot of new uh data about new
developments that are going in that are
intended. Our neighborhood associations
here work very hard to not be nimbies to
have affordable housing go in. And um
there's there's tons of development to
be happening. Um if you close this
school now and close Campbell now and
those developments go in, you may have
to reopen one anyway. So what we're
talking about is is there a way to sort
of find a more temporary solution for
the use of the building space and
preserve the capacity here for the
population that continues to grow in
this area uniquely compared to the rest
of Austin.
And I apologize. I did actually call on
one other person, so I'm gonna let you
have the last word.
>> I'm sorry. Go. Did you
>> I apologize.
>> Yeah. I mean, I I think this is this is
what makes this so hard. I mean, it no
plan is perfect. We're going to have the
conversation with trust. I'm sorry
there. Sorry. No plan is perfect. I I
And this is a this is unique. I mean, I
I I will I going to acknowledge that
there it it is also one of the only
ones. We have three that are wholly into
one school. Um when we talked about the
uh intent of any disruption, trying to
keep communities together was really
really important. I understand the
staffing perspective, but we really
focus on the student. That's where we
start and then we go from there. But
staff is equally important. We just have
different ways to solve for that as this
entire school district. Uh we're going
to have that conversation uh with our
trustees tomorrow about you know what
what we do and what timeline we use.
Ultimately, what I what I'm wanting to
not do is just assume that no change or
no nothing will occur at some point in
the future because we as a system like
there aren't enough partners to fill up
all the spaces. I've been doing this. It
doesn't exist. We have too many empty
seats in Austin ISD and I have to solve
for it and they're not all in one
location. They're spread kind of evenly
throughout. And so, how do you become
more efficient? You have to look at
difficult things.
And
my view
question that was asked earlier
the the attitude that these will be the
recommended schools is confusing to me
because when the rubric came out we were
told it's too soon to talk about
closures. You're not on a closure list.
We don't need to talk about that yet.
But then as soon as the draft came out,
we were told it would be unfair to take
any school off of this list of 13. And
we heard that tonight or this morning
again. Um it would be unfair or it would
create too much additional work to go
back. This is a draft plan and the most
fundamental part of the plan is this
list. So, can you commit that you will
revise the closure list where whether
it's Maplewood or other schools? Can you
commit that based on feedback you've
received and new facts you've gathered,
you will revise the list of 13?
>> So, I I am going to work with our
trustees to get to to consider all of it
because that that that is it is all of
it. What I didn't want to do is um add a
school like what I've gotten into
conversations is where with the
community like what about this other
school? What about that other school?
Like I I I do not want to go down that
road. So if there is a modification,
it's going to be about okay, well, how
do we address this issue? But what in
what time does it absolutely have to be
done?
>> Because the I it would be unfair, I
think, for me to communicate and say
this school that has not been talked
about, has never been part of this this
solution now is going to have a
completely different direction with the
the few days that we have left. Right?
So that that to me would be a different
strategy.
So, so I I want to be really clear. I
want to be really really So, here's the
thing. I want you to be I I want to be
really honest about the number of things
that we're tackling at the same time,
right? You heard us talk about them.
There are there are different moves that
we can make because we're doing all of
it together that don't exist if we're
doing anyone in isolation. Like, if we
were just doing turnaround plans, it
would look very different. If we're just
doing consolidations, it would look
different. If we were just doing program
moves, it would look different. In fact,
you'd have more Esau and schools closed
perhaps if we weren't tackling all of
this together. So, I do not want to
necessarily make a huge shift. The board
will provide that direction and that
conversation to me. It is a draft list.
It it very well could change. It's a
draft plan, but I can't commit to saying
that something will come off or on until
we get through that process. I just I I
just can't give you that guarantee.
>> Okay. And this is going to be the last
Yes. Yes. And that we and the other
thing I want to point out there was a
there's a comment you made around u the
list the rubric uh because I've I've
heard the inverse position as well where
this school was above me on the list.
Why aren't they closing above me? And
and I I want to be really clear like
that was intended to identify where we
have misalignments in our system. That
was a starting point. it was never going
to be the case, you know, and and I I
said that at the time and I think based
on the fact how many of those ultimately
were identified for consolidations, you
know, kind of just prove like we there
are going to you're huge changes all
throughout it, but not all of them are
consolidations. So, I just wanted to
make that point. Thank you.
>> Okay, this is our last comment.
>> Thank you. Um I want to be respectful of
everybody's time. I know we're running
late, so I'm not going to echo everybody
what everybody has said, which is we
love our school. We're a proven school
being successful. Uh we're a very
intentional neighborhood and somebody
that works in low-income housing and
homelessness that is very important to
have neighborhoods open up to such
housing. Um my ask for you when you go
forward because you've heard all
everybody else is the current plan is
based on a one for one, right? So you
are assuming we're losing the building.
We're not I I I
contend that you were telling us we're
going to take Maplewood, right? Students
and we're going to move them over.
Transfers are going to be honored and
unlike 2019, they're going to get
accepted this time. And so our student
body communities moving to Campbell.
What I don't see in this plan is the
real threat of a mass loss of students
to AISD.
So, for example,
I'm a fourth grade parent. I
intentionally moved into this
neighborhood for Maplewood. Um, and so
for us, and I'm a huge supporter of
school of school districts of public
schools. Um, for me, the real question
is my child is going to go through three
transitions. fifth grade in Campbell.
Let's say the plan passes. Fifth grade
in Campbell and then sixth grade in
Keeling and then those group of students
are going to get split again into
different high schools, right? No longer
McCullum in the proposed plan. So for me
the question now and then this goes a
little bit back to your timeline and why
we were mentioning charters and private
schools. It's a really tough decision to
stay with AISD given that my child's
going to get such disruptions right at a
time where core education needs to be
the priority. He is a minority student.
So a lot of the things that you're
talking about here are directly
impacting my kids and I know I'm not
alone, right? Especially not with other
fourth grade parents that are going to
have the same transition. our community
as a whole is going to have another big
shift in um when they get to high
school. And so I think and my educ my
background is not in education, but I do
believe that this whole cohort of
students are not going to be set up for
success when they reach high school,
which then will have a tremendous impact
of what happens after that. So my
question to you is, has this been
discussed? Um, and I know there's
attrition, people move, there's the
regular percentage that school districts
lose, but this is one real
great number where in mass you could
potentially be losing a lot of the
savings that you are assuming you're
going to have by closing Maple Whitney.
>> Yeah. So, so, um, two things and then I
know we're it's already we'll wrap it
up. I'm happy. Again, I I I very much
appreciate this conversation. I I I am
trying to get everywhere. I really am.
Um, I will get to Campbell. The
uh the one thing I will say is um
regarding student movement, right, and
the number of transitions your students
going to to have to, you know, endure uh
through their academic journey in Austin
ISD over 13 or 14 years. Um, that's what
we're trying to get away from as a whole
system because right now we have
families that have five and six. I mean,
there there are families that have
multiple transitions in Austin ISTD now.
We're trying to alleviate that and have
it be stable for years to come. So, yes,
right now there's going to be
disruption. I'm assuming you're talking
about Northeast Early College High
School versus Macallum. And so, the
question I have is I want families to
feel as though Northeast Early College
High School like is a welcoming, loving
school that has the academic rigor so
that you are comfortable sending your
student there. That's what we need to do
as a school system. There shouldn't be a
Macallum in the Northeast. Hey,
I I understand that there are schools
that have different programs in Austin
ISD. You have IB at Anderson. You have
AP at some schools. You have early East
Side early college. You have early
college high school experiences. We
academically can make those adjustments,
but we don't have the resources to be
able to do so. And we are being
intentional. We're being forward facing.
So, we're looking at those um those uh
classes and those um in the student
pathways and ensuring that they're going
to be there when your student um is
there. We're doing that analysis. Now,
the other thing that I wanted to talk
about was um students leaving, right? I
will always tell a family to do what's
best for their student. Period. I I
believe in that. I do think Austin IST I
do believe in public education. Product
of it. My kids come here. Like, I just
I'm all in. The one thing I'll say is
there are lots of families who've chosen
to leave Austin ISD because in those
parts of the city, they don't have
strong neighborhood schools. That's just
the honest truth. And we don't have the
ability to fund them. Like I can I
>> There's se there's seven
>> no
right in the future. So for us part of
what and Adam correct me if I'm speaking
incorrectly here uh is the immediate
right. So you are having a a subset of
students that are going to carry this
setback several years right and we know
history has shown once you have begun at
a disadvantage and this is a huge
disadvantage not just the transition and
I'm not talking about the building right
I'm talking about something that you
can't assure us today and I understand
why you can't you can't assure that
you're going to take the staff and the
teachers that are in Maplewood that have
led us here
>> all staff Right. You can't take all
staff.
>> I want to be very clear because people
have been saying that back and forth
that you said all staff. That was the
guarantee I couldn't make.
>> Right. That's the guarantee you can't
make. But as we all know, all staff and
I think one of your members spoke about
this when we had a new principal. There
were some growing pains, right? We
overcame that, but it took time. And so
that's the time that our fourth graders,
our fifth graders, they don't have that.
And so with us asking for, hey, let's
slow down a little bit. We are not um we
understand budgetary constraints. We
understand where we are and we need
change. I don't think anybody's arguing
against change. I think we're arguing
against the um lack of time and
transparency.
And so that that um we would fully
support your plan should we have a
slower time frame. And people have been
throwing around a year or other things.
I don't know what the magic number is,
but I do know a month is not. And so if
we could take this plan that you
currently have and do it in phases or
perhaps spend a little bit more time
ironing out these things so that we have
more time to make the better choice for
our students.
Okay, I'm just going to go ahead and go
over the timeline. We've talked a lot
about these dates and sometimes said the
wrong dates, so I just want to make sure
we're all on the same page. But that
board workshop is this evening. Um
you're welcome to tune in. I think it's
from 6 to 8 9 somewhere in there. Um
then the release of the the revised
draft will be this Friday. Um and that
that revised draft will then again be
discussed at the November 6th board
meeting. So that's the next Thursday. Um
and then we have our November 20th board
um voting meeting is when the the final
plan is anticipated to be voted on. Um,
and so, and then of course, as of right
now, we're recommending these changes go
into effect for the 2627
school year. Um, I want to thank
everyone for your time. Um, I know that
Matias has to get out of here, but a lot
of us will probably be able to stay if
there's still questions we didn't get
to. Um, and we will definitely be in
touch with you and making sure that we
find um, time in our schedules. It may
not be before this Friday, but we can
assure that it will be before the vote
that we can get with your community. Um,
so thank you everyone and I'm going to
give it to Principal No because I think
she has some announcements.
>> All right. Thank you. Thank you, central
office. Thank you, Matias. Appreciate
you guys. Um,
we love you guys. Thank you for showing
up for your kids. Uh, thank you to our
guests, um, wherever you're from. Uh,
thank you for making kids a priority,
um, and choosing to spend part of your
day and definitely part of your lives.
Uh thank you for your commitment to uh
ensure that these conversations are
adult conversations and that we uh
protect our kids and let them be joyful
uh learners in our schools. Uh both
Principal Moore and I are fully
committed to joyful teaching and
learning every single day. Um I have
visited with him.
we're both on board with whatever uh is
passed and approved and however that we
can be a part of setting up this new uh
school if it passes uh in order for
success. And we do both feel that it can
be the best of us and the best of them
coming together to be the best new
situation if that's what we're asked to
do. Uh we also believe that a rising
tide raises all boats and uh that's the
mindset that we're in right now. Uh but
we do have our eye on the ball and our
eye on the ball is very much what's
happening in each of our buildings. Uh
so just take heart um if it passes, if
it doesn't, that you have principles
that 100% love what they do. I know
Principal Moore is 100% committed um to
seeing out his passion in service for
public ed and for Campbell Elementary
and I'm 100% fully committed uh to
seeing my Mustangs thrive and accelerate
to middle school. Um
it's hard because it means something.
So, thank you for being real and thank
you for being present. Uh we are going
to fully uh continue to commit to keep
loving and teaching here. Um we will see
you uh someday very very soon. Uh
Maplewood hopefully at the book uh
character parade on Friday. Uh you know
where to reach us. Um please love on
your teachers and thank you Maplewood.
>> I'll one I'll let that announcement in
just a second but thank you so much
again. I don't know if you were a part
of my last meeting, but thank you for a
commitment to giving our teachers grace
and space uh to be able to process what
they need to process um as an employee
and as a teacher uh without having to
help you process uh what your family
needs to process. So, thank you for that
commitment for my teachers to be able
just to emotionally uh be present with
uh what they're going through as well.
And please send notes of encouragement.
Uh there's never a teacher uh that needs
to go longer than a week without a great
note of encouragement uh the way that
they're pouring into your kids. Uh I
love you Maplewood. Thank you again and
um I'll turn it over for one quick
announcement and thank you central
office. I really appreciate you. I know
that your work is still there and that
you've chosen to invest in us. Um thank
you so much. I know that you sometimes
feel that that they're not doing enough,
but they do so much so that I can do
what I need to do so that your teacher
can do what they need to do. So, it is
very much uh a bucket filler system and
um we we would not be where we're at
without the support uh that I do get on
a daily basis from central. So, thank
you central office. And uh a quick
announcement.
>> Uh thank you again AISD staff. We wanted
to invite you this evening. I know you
are all busy now, but we are having a
concert and rally. We thought that was
the perfect way to exemplify the
Maplewood spirit at Cherrywood Coffee
House from 5:00 to 8. So, if anyone can
make it, we'd love to have you there.
Obviously, everyone else, we'd love to
have you there. Celebrate this amazing
community. I'd also just like to mention
that our trustee, our district one
trustee, uh, Miss Hunter is here and
she's been listening to the meeting. Hi.
And she has offered to stick around as
well and speak with families. And so,
uh, she will be our advocate, uh, with
the board and we'll be working with
them, uh, with the the district this
evening. So, uh, she is definitely a
resource as well. And then thank you for
offering to stay around here as well.
>> And this is from us.
>> All right. Thank you, Maplewood.